welcome to this video playing drain you
sooner berg Enza this here recently
wonder the danish championships just
completed a couple of days ago um okay I
had this earlier but he did not play d5
him yeah Queen a5 is what they play here
nowadays I never really looked at that
with Queen h5 to come and III that's a
very conservative way to play okay I
cannot go these six year maybe I can
maybe they're there are those those
sacrifices Bishop takes Knight six
now maybe I can still play that I don't
see how to develop otherwise I mean I
can go I could have played night XD for
it looks let look strange and if he
grabs now on c6 I should have a decent
version of this kind of porn sacrifice
knight c6 b96 bc look be eight that
looks decent we cannot easily develop a
screen side Bishop takes pawn takes
Knight takes Queen c7 yeah okay is
playing it conservatively so um what am
I going to do here i can try tune can I
try to be active yeah if I go queen age
five is going and let's do that it was
one of the ideas here you can go neither
for a further for the trade okay okay so
what now I'd like to attack like to
attack you the c-4 pawn maybe this were
the temple yes f3 is not a happy move
but he probably has to play that so
probably rook c8 next rook FC eight
he tries to prepare I wonder this is an
idea and 95 is always happening okay
let's go let's go here so that I have
King f8 available if he if he goes 95
can actually do this as a prophylactic
measure maybe I'd naija form okay okay I
always play Knight ff2 e2 back if he
wants
okay I sc5 now immediately as you AF
Bishop before check okay that's good my
DS night c76 fighting for deform but I
oh I forgot about c5 okay that sets of
course welcome let's just straight stuff
and now c5 is c5 coming now I have to
play be six then make sure that it's not
happening I'm glad that he traded the
dark squared bishop that's definitely an
achievement for black okay I can't play
your sexy on it it's no big issue there
the pawn on d6 looks weak but I have
Rupert e8 and stuff no problem
that's no problem at all i think okay so
push it back I'd like night six seven I
would like to put something on deformed
in an ideal world this would be would be
happening somehow this world isn't so
ideal as we tend to find out quite often
okay night here that was the idea what's
he playing for f45 maybe maybe maybe
I was playing for pawn to e5 myself but
not sure that I ever get this on and if
I get this going it's probably far too
ambitious now that I look at it ok can I
go here is a 6b five maybe check
sometimes sometimes you're just so
stupid ruki one that sets the most crude
way to prepare 95 and I completely
overlook that yeah that that's
immediately lost them great great great
great great is it lost probably yeah
what's that nonsense right there was
nothing absolutely nothing if I just um
if I just don't blunder into 95 yeah
rook do you want now is good you can
argue can argue him maybe it's still not
lost here it looks bad but maybe I can
still somehow who would this stuff my
rook do you won't have to play 98 which
is more than awkward can pre move that
he praying it probably won't play a good
hmm his Texas time this is really not
very nice but I have to do that check
this is the problem you're sitting there
with this really weak pawn what is an
idea here would be 77 97 and ultimately
d5
the only thing I have to say is I was
rather quick in playing this nonsense
time morning I can just take h7
it didn't he somehow it didn't connect
till I go to c5 that looks kind of shaky
but it might irritate him check come on
let's do that cheeks I'm going to take
him maybe t5 not see father be a smooth
okay so probably this move check check
oh I didn't even see that it hang that
that it did hang while okay no 94 is a
huge problem ok check night c5 is a
threat check check
wait for it oh that was a victory of
nerves or whatever but it was really bad
disposition but some for some reason he
took ages in China Chang moment I don't
know who I here okay it was a great
position for him and I would have taken
some time as well but one minute is
maybe a bit too much and why it is
better almost in any mood any move I'm
not sure maybe he was from unknown jack
is just excellent when but I had somehow
he kept things going and not I didn't
lose a mediately yeah I can take age 70
that that was that was Miss there but I
was of course also not exactly having
much time he can take ages have nuts
much better he keeps an advantage in any
case we shouldn't be argue about that
chad is this should win somehow king of
three it's the computer move yeah I
cannot take the IES has chastened and
picks picks up stuff the rock t4 is also
good yeah i'm vers all the way that's
true but here I'm kind of kind of back
in the game and now it's of course a
crapshoot there with no time but he he
really had a bad time management they're
spending too much in this position where
basically everything was good okay well
thanks for watching